did I mention it was a masked ball the
masquerade ball lends a sense of mystery
to film masquerade balls something put
on by Kristin's parents fours already
and it is so massive and the colors are
very saturated it just looks incredible
one of the big set pieces in darker is a
big masquerade gala Alice mammoth
undertaking which I give Nelson coats
the production designer a lot of credit
for there's so much I can do non we had
all kinds of characters like fire
breathers acrobatics it's actually
incredible
we had 200 guests that all needed to be
in venetian masks outfits every single
mosque was embellished with additional
head pieces which went with whatever the
costume was it was fabulous the whole
place is just an explosion of color from
the costumes and the set design all with
this Venice backdrop and it's quite a
magical movie moment its lavish its
sensuous and it looks fabulous is the
sort of place you think I wish it was
there everybody's looking at us not us
[Music]
you